on the big bang theory penny has  occasionally shared tidbits about her  quirky family from omaha nebraska but  only a few appeared during the show's  12th season run most notably wyatt  penny's father along with having a  brother randall who is best known for  his history cooking meth penny mentions  having a sister a few times in the show  the sister who drunkenly shot her own  husband and gave penny her first bikini  wax using melted crayons while penny's  brother dad and mom susan all attend  penny and leonard's second wedding  ceremony in the first episode of season  10 her sister is nowhere to be seen and  is never even mentioned a pretty big  plot hole if you ask us in season 12  however we at least finally learn  penny's mysterious sister's name lisa  being your dad is the best thing ever  happened to me  what about randall and lisa  they're okay